the asian owners of two of the country's
shipbuilders have filed for insolvency
it's after the firms failed to weather
the drop in demand for cruise liners and
mega yachts brought on by the pandemic
just days after the suspension of share
trading in the cruise giant genting hong
kong mv veriftin and lloyd verift have
filed for bankruptcy
trade unions are calling it a dark day
for german shipyards as the ship
builders become the latest victims of a
pandemic-driven disaster in cruise
tourism
for genting the crisis has meant more
than 2 billion dollars in losses
meanwhile 2000 employees in vismar
may not get their december wages
the mood is bad because of the situation
the german government says it is
prepared to provide aid to the troubled
company but that it has not received
assurances from genting that it will
also provide financial support for mv
verfton
yet
now we're hoping that the employees get
their salary for december and that they
find a solution so we can continue to
build this beautiful ship here
that beautiful ship is the colossal 1.5
billion euro global dream cruise ship a
project currently in jeopardy for lack
of financing it remains a dream as the
world waits for recovery from the
pandemic
you